hi everybody
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale program for the study of
anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you here today to the next in our
benjamin
and barbara zucker lecture series it's
an especially great pleasure to welcome
today's
speaker adam stern back to yale
some of you remember that adam was a
postdoctoral fellow in our program a few
years ago
when he was finishing up the book that
he's going to be talking about today
called survival a theological political
genealogy
which has now been released by
university of pennsylvania press and i
just received my copy
yesterday adam received his ba
from colombia his m.a from university of
chicago and his phd from harvard
in the study of religion he's now an
assistant professor of german
at the university of wisconsin-madison
where he teaches courses on continental
philosophy
jewish thought race and religion
secularism political theology
translation theory and media studies
he's going to be in conversation
today with my colleague in the german
department paul north
paul is well known to most of you uh
among
other things he's the author of the
yield kafka's
a theological reformation published by
stanford in 2015
and a new book that i have to say sounds
incredibly cool
called bizarre privileged items in the
universe
the logic of likeness literally just out
last week
from zone books so here's how things are
going to work
adam is going to present his book for
about 10 minutes
then paul will engage him in
conversation then we'll open it up to
questions from the audience please
submit questions using the q
a function at the bottom of your screen
not chat you can submit questions at any
time during the presentation
and paul will ask them and we're going
to finish
promptly at six so i will now uh
mute my video and hand it over to adam
thanks very much maury for the kind
introduction and
uh for hosting this event and um also to
uh paul north for agreeing to
participate into anessa
laskova for helping to organize the
event
um so as maurice said i'm just going to
speak for a few minutes
um and then we'll proceed with some
discussion
so my book began with a few observations
the first was that survival occupies a
prominent place within the modern
secular political imagination
one you'd only think of the ways that
the figure of the survivor has come to
mediate the representation
of current events from genocide climate
catastrophe and mass shootings
and disaster capitalism to nuclear war
terminal illness
and perhaps in the post-fortis present
everyday life
the second was that one could also
identify a popular association between
survival and jews
consider here not only the primacy
accorded to the holocaust survivor in
our time
but also the extent to which survival
underwrites the narration
of both jewish history the survival of
the jews and jewish politics
the survival of the israeli state the
question i wanted to ask was this
what if anything unites these two
horizons
could an examination of secular survival
shed light on the issue of jewish
survival
and what could a study of jewish
survival tell us about the dissemination
of survival more broadly
it became clear at an early stage in the
research that any attempt to write
this history would have to go beyond two
major themes or areas
darwinism and the holocaust neither
biology nor biopolitics seem to fully
account for the theological
and theological political resonances of
the discourse on jewish survival
my hunch moreover was that any
theological political perspective
on survival or jewish survival would
have to acknowledge
the codes sedimented by the asymmetric
legacy of the jewish christian debate
so this gave rise to a hypothesis
perhaps the link between jewish survival
and secular survival could be found in
the invisible space
between and in the very thing that
otherwise managed to erase itself
from view the theological political
history of christianity
so this book interrogates the
possibility
that lion christianity has played an
overwhelming role in shaping survival
as a word theme and figure more than
that the book is an attempt to follow
the language of survival as it modulates
disarticulates and rearranges
a number of categorical distinctions
between things like the secular the
jewish the judeo-christian
and the christian my strategy
throughout is to read secular and or
jewish writers who have contributed or
been made to contribute to the vast
proliferation
of survival talk what i tend to show
is that these arguments arguments that
appear to highlight the secular
and or jewish signature of survival also
consent
and even demand attention to a different
set of readings
again and again they return survival to
a latinate field of translation
to scenes of incarnation passion and
resurrection
in short to a stage dominated by the
sovereign triumphalism
of christ's body in this sense
the book is less a history of survival
than a genealogy of its force
and i'll talk a little bit more about
what i mean by genealogy in a minute
it doesn't seek to address the whole of
manifest survival's manifold uses
forge a linear narrative of its
development or contextualize it in
reference to a single historical event
instead the book moves backward from the
present
in order to rewrite the interpretive
regimes that have dominated survival
circulation
these genealogies of survival take major
texts of 20th century philosophy
theology and political theory
as sites or occasions for collecting
and constellating the scattered elements
of survival's
theological political archive my hope
in the book is that this will establish
a framework for thinking survival is
christian question and in doing so
offer a critical assessment of
christianity's role in the constitution
of modern secular and jewish
politics um
in order to frame all of these issues i
begin with a single question
which is who is speaking about survival
and the question seeks to highlight the
genealogical objective of the study
my central purpose is not to affirm or
deny survival
it's not to accept or reject its
rhetoric or to say yes or no
to the stances it defines instead
following
um michel foucault's famous definition
of genealogy or at least one of them
the task is to gauge the fact that
survival is spoken about
to discover who does the speaking the
position and viewpoints from which they
speak
uh the institutions which prompt people
to speak about survival
and which store and distribute the
things that are said
in other words i use genealogy as a
scheme for
provincializing the presumed
universality of
these codes and
ask how speech that has not always been
self-evident to everyone has been made
to look
obvious and universal my goal
that is is to say that genealogy of
survival is not a history of survival
but instead a way of asking
where such a history might begin what
are survival's limits what are its
archives what are its languages
and importantly in the book what field
of translations mediate
its generalization so
the genealogy presented over the course
of the book
is at best a prologue to a history that
has not
really been written though restrictive
and partial
the aspirational constraints acknowledge
the need for a preparatory inventory of
the major questions
texts and structures of speaking that
have made
survival an identifiable element of our
current political horizon
um in doing this
my preliminary hypothesis is that
the genealogy of genealogy of survival
should begin with the specific
political and theological political
anxieties surrounding the survival of
the jews
in choosing this point of departure i'm
not arguing for a direct
and transparent return to the jewish
textual tradition
but rather for a more complex encounter
with the vicissitudes of history and
translation that have contributed to the
adoption of this language by both jews
and others
the political theorist robert meister
motions in a helpful direction here i
think
by speculating that the political
political prominence of jewish survival
is as much about jews as it is about the
christian west
and the history of the jewish question
that goes as far back as paul
why are there still jews now
this insight could take the genealogy of
survival in a number of directions
on the one hand a shared concern with
jewish survival
could serve as a means of reconciling
the commonalities of
a judeo-christian treatment
that runs from the bible to the present
day on the other hand
survival could also be an opportunity to
explore the
historical grammar of concepts
underlying secularism
critics of secularism like talal assad
for instance
have argued that the judeo-christian
heritage assumed by
modern secularity is actually a
retrospective reconstruction
whose vision of unity has particular
political stakes in assad's word
uh quote the grammatical exclusion of
muslims
the problem is that neither meister nor
assad
ever really divest themselves of the
suspicion that the secular embrace of a
judeo-christian past
is really just the reiteration of an
older christian perspective on the
theological place of the jews and
christendom
that it's a kind of redescription a
supersessional redescription of
christianity itself
um in this light i approach jewish
survival
neither as a jewish nor as a
judeo-christian question
but instead as a counterintuitive index
for the way that survival
explains reflects the secularized forms
of christianity that mark modernity in
the west
of course versions of this claim are by
now familiar
few philosophers philosophers of
religion for example
would be surprised to learn that
christianity provides the inescapable
backdrop to western philosophy
the same statement could apply as much
to individual thinkers
explicitly involved in projects like
de-theologization
as it could to more abstract and
far-reaching endeavors
to unearth the theological traces at
play in
something like modern political economy
and yet the stark
obviousness of christianity's
significance has not necessarily led to
any
further clarity on the kind of object or
subject
that christianity is which is to say
that
even the most sophisticated genealogical
work sometimes struggles to contain the
slippages between christianity
and a host of other historically
freighted terms
um not the least of which would be the
word religion
this translation between christianity
and religion
um in order to open this up in a
different way
um i'd borrow from a term that jacques
gary dot
coined um toward the end of his career
namely
global atomization this kind of
neologism
that attempts to combine um latin
christianity
with the centuries-long process of
universalization
um that gary dot also calls
globalization
what this also implies uh for me what
this term
global latinization implies is that
the question i've been asking who is
speaking about religion
cannot ignore the fact that the name
survival
as with the name religion um we are we
are already speaking latin
so my genealogy begins also as an
investigation
into the history of translation as it
makes its way from rome in terms like
superstar a super vivarium to europe
survival
service to the united states in english
against survival
and has become part again of our current
political
horizon to borrow a quote from saba
mahmoud
one might say that survival is
symptomatic of the fundamental
centrality of christian norms values and
sensibilities
however judaic they are made out to be
to european conceptions
of what it means to be secular so one
final question
um before i end how does this work in
the book
as i've said um i look at a series of
canonical writers
um hannah arendt walter benjamin franz
rosenzweig and
sigmund freud and again the question is
why these
canonical and familiar names so just a
few comments on that choice
in choosing them i'm compelled by two
strategies
first because the work of arent
rosenstein and freud has been so central
to the post-war expression of jewish
survival their writings are also
effective sites for provisionally
disarticulating
these two terms jewish and survival
second because the writings of rn
benjamin and freud have circulated well
beyond
the discourse on jewish survival and
become major resources
in the propagation of survival talk
across
geographic and topical contexts
they can also serve as occasions for
real
reorienting along global latin lines
survival's theological political
genealogy
um just two quick examples
in the chapter or actually we'll stay
with one example
in the chapter on rnt which
[Music]
um my claim is survival
this word survival runs like a red
thread through
the book the origins of totalitarianism
stringing together its intersecting
analyses of anti-semitism imperialism
and totalitarianism
and so through a comparative reading of
these sections and their respective
representations of jewish survival what
are
what aren calls jewish survival african
survival and european survival
i established aaron's text as a kind of
digest for thinking about
survival's theological political archive
i do this across each section um until
the story culminates in a striking image
that aaron borrows from a number of
figures in her own time that
finds the description of the
concentration camps in which
the figure of the survivor is lazarus
um saved and resurrected from the ruin
of a ghostly realm that are in herself
and
a kind of racializing narrative that has
been picked up by others
um continually compares to quote the
dark continent
and so survival becomes a way of
thinking about how a series of things
religion
race sovereignty um and so forth
um can be thought within the history of
a christian theological
political archive and what some of those
elements might look like
um i will stop here um and
we can begin the discussion
thanks adam yeah well there's a lot to
take up in what you say and a lot to
take up in the book
i appreciate having read it and i
appreciate the attempt
to um save jews from survival
it's a loaded term as you show it's
loaded in a whole bunch of different
ways in fact
it seems as you read through the book
you discover that it is connected to so
many different
problematic projects you could say
that i begin to wonder this is my first
question to you
um it's a general question and then i
want to get to some specifics in the
book
what's the alternative have you
thought of the real work that this term
does
for people in valorizing their
experience
i see it as and i'm with you in your
critiques
all the way through i can see exactly
where it comes from
but i see it as an indicator of an
unsettled relationship
to finitude that is the accounts have
not been settled on one's own
limitations and also on the death of
others
and survival is as you show at times a
triumphant
response and at times a melancholic
response
and it oscillates between the two but it
does do that work
right so yes this is this is um this is
a crucial question
i think um which i'm understanding um in
two ways one is that the way that um
survival
captures both these triumphant moments
and this melancholic moments or even
say ghostly moments um as i talk about
in some
portions of the book and so um
if survival is doing this kind of
important work if it's capturing
not just one particular figure but a
whole range of possibilities say in a
reaction to finitude or
reaction to the death of others then um
is there an alternative or should we
hold on to survival
for some reason um and i think um that's
completely possible it's possible to
make an argument that we should hold on
to survival as doing some kind of work
my sense is that um actually um even in
places like the popular media there's
something um
pushing against um survival and even the
figure of the survivor
um not simply because of the um content
um
that it holds but also um perhaps
because of the
um affect that it creates or the
obviousness
of the terms that it brings together for
one thing um i think it still
is um related to a kind of
post-holocaust discourse
that
has certain familiar images certain
familiar um
figurations that have come to color all
sorts of things um as i point out in the
introduction related to the cold war and
and so forth
um and the question is whether um
beginning elsewhere
um is possible and this is something
that i suggest um
uh at the end of the book um with an
attempt um with a kind of
um displacement of translation to think
um
outside the history of um uh
um latin christianity and in relation to
a series of
kind of figure of translation in hebrew
and arabic
that would provide not necessarily a
postwar american or
post political orientation
um but maybe a kind of post-colonial
colonial orientation to thinking about
some of the similar
questions of infi finitude and so forth
that you bring up
just one other example though i think
survive also creates a kind of
problematic bind
um there are two recent books that i've
found helpful in thinking about this one
is a kind of
ongoing project summarized recently by
mahmoud mandani
where he tries to suggest that what's so
important about the figure of the
survivor
in say post-genocidal context
is the way that it overcomes the
difference between victim and
perpetrator and that it can actually for
that reason be a kind of
reconciliatory term for thinking about
um
those who have been survived
um a genocidal uh context
on the other hand there's another book
that's come out recently um
by um si haika shoten a scholar in
boston um who suggests that the
triumphalism of the survivors
survivors always connected somehow to
settler colonial movements or
the triumph of the survivor as the
triumph of the perpetrator
always in some way this overcoming of
victimhood the death of others the
denial of
the passivity of victimhood and so for
that reason you're caught somehow in a
double bind what kind of
work is survival doing is it a kind of
productive agency
or is it a denial of another mode of
subjectivity
um that wouldn't have that triumphalism
kind of baked into it
yeah that's a great point maybe we could
talk then about your reading
of of a gamben
and the idea of the muslin
this becomes so the book takes you
through a whole series
of versions of survival i can just read
some of them
survival of as you said the savage quote
unquote
which is a shocking revelation about
aurent's
thought of what she calls the dark
continent
the fort laden or the living fourth of
texts in benyamin
the imitation of christ in rosensweig
the eucharistic
presence of the absent body of god which
also shows up as a gesture of media
and so on there's a number of them but
then you get towards the end
to the question
of a social relationship
where the survivor is always a survivor
with relationship to someone whose
um life doesn't count even if they
survive
would you talk a little bit about that
sure thanks paul um can you just tell me
what um what um
point you're referring to um uh
at the end i'm trying to find it here in
my
various notes
i think i'm talking about
i can answer in relationship to a gambin
if that why don't you use that and then
i'll look for my
yeah i mean so right so you know you
know
famously um again makes this argument
about
um survival in remnants of auschwitz as
a
uh kind of um actually uh intervention
into this famous difference that
foucault suggests between making dai and
making live agon suggests to make
survive as a kind of mechanism of
differentiation
between say survivors on the one hand
and what he calls
the muslim or the muslim in auschwitz
which
has been of course written about
extensively
and what i try to do is not so much
disagree with agambin but suggest that
his own genealogical work in remnants of
auschwitz
ends up creating kind of distinction
between the theological
um say the remnant of the remnant the
remnant of israel
um and the biopolitical which he
associates with survival
but that his actual genealogy of
survival although alluding at moments to
a theological heritage
never really doubles down on that
um and keeps these two things separate
the biopolitical and the theological
and what i try to suggest then is that
um oddly enough
maybe not oddly i don't know
one can actually think about um the way
that franz rosenstein's
book written um well before the context
that um agambin is writing about um
already seems to be um
working across similar lines um in the
sense
that um the survivor has this
triumphalist aspect to it
that um the muslim is coded according to
a particular history of
uh despotism that marks the muslim with
uh
death and that the entire um discourse
of survival in rosenstein's book somehow
circles around his understanding of the
body of
christ and so in that sense
rosenstein's book becomes a kind of
supplement
i don't know retrospective supplement uh
to um agon's work to suggest that this
isn't maybe about
um uh the holocaust itself but there's a
older lineage um for thinking about the
way that the language of survival
mediates
um our reception of things like
um those whose lives matter those whose
lives don't matter as you put it as you
put it earlier
i see so just to go a little
further with the distinction between the
theopolitical
use of the term and reception from
christian theological paths which you
trace back to pseudodionysis
and neoplatonism and the biopolitical i
can see very much the stakes
with the biopolitical which is a term
invented by foucault in late lectures
to talk about the way uh governments
manage
biological life of their
of the governed and so
um the idea of survival in a
biopolitical realm
could issue in violence against the
physical life of certain members of the
community
it's a kind of logic of sacrifice there
what are the stakes of the
theo-political
is it just that people are
crypto-christians i kind of aren't or
benjamin may be less and they're waiting
for
an afterlife a perfect life in some
sense you suggest this and rosensweigs
the end of rosenzweig's book where one
goes into life
that has to be shorn of all its other
characteristics it's hard to know what
that is
what are the stakes of the theopolo
political reading what are we
what are we losing there
well well let me let me answer this
question in two ways so
the first thing to say is that i don't i
don't know that that
um aren't ben you mean these these
figures are exactly
crypto christian um the
or at least my attempt is not to sort of
make a challenge toward any kind of
identity claim
um what i'm actually trying to suggest
is that the identity claims sometimes
predetermines or over determines the way
that we read these
texts and then in fact one can read
books by rm by benjamin and so forth
as helping to um assemble this
theological political archive
especially in particularly in regard to
survival
um the stakes um i think um if i'm
understanding your question correctly
and as i was suggesting as well in the
opening remarks
is that survival is already one could
say
um theological if you're uh read
the link between jews and survival as
marking survival in some way with
religion or theology and in fact there's
a whole tradition both in modern
scholarship and
in older scholarship of trying to read
jewish theology the history of jewish
textual tradition through the language
of survival
and so the stakes for me are to
disarticulate
these things and suggest that the
language of survival actually emerges
um not only from a christian theological
tradition
but um actually captures um jews
as a theological category through
the language of survival through the
augustinian tradition and so forth
and it's this um called a theological
political reorientation but also a
geopolitical reorientation to the extent
that
terms like judeo-christian um i think
gloss over
um the stakes of thinking about
um what it might mean to set
um uh jewishness off or
the history of jewish textual tradition
whatever it might be off
from the kind of obviousness of survival
as a
link between them i think it's a it's a
great discovery and it's really useful
for
understanding how one is read through
the other
i guess i would say and i wonder if you
agree here
that it's a particular interpretation of
a relationship to loss
a recuperative relationship
and i can see how the structures that
you bring in to understand survival
the eucharist the passion of christ
god as the ultimate uber labender
survivor
who has eternal life and then you raise
the wonderful question
what is what is life it really depends
what you mean by life
when you're saying someone survives i
think of um
soma morgenstern who was a friend of
benjamin's who came to new york after
the award
he had survived but he he really didn't
feel like that word was the right word
it felt like the most thin of existence
is
um so
well i want to ask what you think about
that as a a certain interpretation of
loss and again if you have
an alternative that you want to propose
right i mean i i think i think that's
that's right um
in all of the examples um that i give um
it's structured in some way around this
question of
of loss um and things like the eucharist
god's survival so forth our reactions to
this
possibility of finitude and um loss
um
so the question i think
for me is not whether um survival is so
much a good description
of this question of loss um
as you say it does a lot of does a lot
of work um
but for me i think the question is how
um
central um this question of survival
becomes
in relationship to loss for
understanding subjectivity
in general and to me that's not a clear
um leap and certainly the freudian
tradition
even up through um uh contemporary
theory
judith butler and so forth um this link
say between melancholia triumphant
melancholia
and the constitution of of the subject i
think is something that should just at
least be
you know thought about um in in this
genealogical way and so
um while i do propose a kind of
alternative at some point
um my goal my preliminary goal
with the book is to raise these
questions as perhaps being more
contingent
than um they would sometimes suggest
um and so the next step then would be to
think about
um what an alternative might look like
though i i will
leave that to uh scholars more more
ambitious than i
yeah maybe i'll just ask you one more
question and that's about maybe the most
peculiar and complicated figure of
survival in your book and that is
i think ben yamin's idea of the fort
laden of a text the living forth
of a text into its nach life
its post-ripeness or the ripeness of its
post age
this is certainly not a triumphant
triumphalist view
and it's it is um not really about
human beings in any of the senses as
quasi theological beings as imitations
of christ
how do you see that fitting in
right so um i think you're right i think
um the
chapter on benjamin is a is stands in an
interesting
relationship to the chapter that
precedes it rns which is about
um political questions and so forth and
um some of the theological work that i
do in the rest of the
book afterwards uh specifically in
relate relationship to things uh
concerning christ's body and the
eucharist and so forth um
for me um benjamin does a couple things
one is that
um to the extent that there is a
contemporary philosophical discourse
about survival
um it emerges um in a strange way
um um in relationship to benjamin's text
on um translation this this
apparent distinction it's not even clear
benjamin makes a distinction but
um derrida has suggested at some point
that there was a distinction between
um fond laban and uben and that one
could
map these along different different
lines living living on versus living
after
um so for one thing um that
linguistic difference um and its
afterlife
in contemporary philosophy was helpful
for orienting the
problem as one of translation that one
of the issues with survival is that i
wanted to use translation to make it
less transparent
as a category and think about the way
that across
languages um translation creates
problems for thinking about exactly what
survival is doing um but
in doing that what i try to show um is
that
as much as benjamin writes about the
thought laben
of the text um uh uberlaben somehow
has a less clear uh set of uses
um and yet what i try to suggest is that
the term uberlaben itself or that ben
means text is an opportunity for
thinking about the history of
the translation of that word and the way
that benjamin uses it
um and that there are ways of reading
benjamin's text especially toward the
end
with the notion of a kind of
performative language
that is translatable
less as survival or translatable as
survival but in the particular sense of
kind of hyper life
or super life um and what i try to show
as you mentioned
is that um my hypothesis is
disconnectedly traced back
um to um the text of
pseudo dionysius where the idea of super
life
um is a description of god's
sovereignties or apophatically
you know registered um but um that this
construction um
as hyper life um one can actually follow
a history of translation
through translations of pseudo-dionysius
texts into german
so um benjamin does some some work for
me
linguistically and um archivally i would
say
yeah i guess in preparation for the rest
right i found it a really interesting
chapter and you come back to benjamin
later
to talk about the aura as a form of
survival
i guess i would say that one valence of
survival
is this again in a kind of
particular spot in a christian tradition
that there's some precious stuff call it
spirit
that is carried over but benjamin when
he comes to it
really thinks nothing is carried over
that's the interesting part of it that
the translation touches
the original at a certain part but
there isn't a preservation there
so it could offer another another model
where instead of surviving you're in
fact departing from a certain spot
um right no i i think i think this is
right and
um um
i mean you know obviously people like um
sam weber and so forth have kind of
opened up this term
fraud label in interesting ways and um
this departing from a text and
into the text of another and so forth
and i think these i think these readings
are
benjamin are all um correct um
um
what's interesting actually is in that
chapter um in the particular valence
that
laban takes on is it's actually not
clear that it's about preservation
at all um um and that in some sense um
it's an attempt to actually
understand what it would mean to have a
language without
content that preserves nothing but is
actually
creative um as a creative in some
powerful way and this is what i what i
think it does for
i'm thinking about this term um
and it's um difference if it is one um
from
the way that font label tracks this
becoming other of the text across the
rest of
the essay
well terrific thank you for talking with
me i'm going to open up the floor to
question no thank you thank you paul i
appreciate it the total pleasure
i'm going to turn to the q a now and i
will i'm going to um well since i didn't
ask whether people wanted to be named i
guess i won't name the people who
who are asking but i will ask your
questions
here's a question about christianity as
a question
and which is the christianity you're
talking about
he wants to know or she wants to know
[Music]
what is the state of the christian
question in your work
um yes it it remains a question um or at
least
um i think um um if uh
um my understanding of uh the state of
the christian question is
correct is that um it is a question that
um um
maybe is um uh still
uh burgeoning strangely enough that it
still needs to be asked um in a
particular way
and um my hope then is that um this
question of survival is a way of opening
up
what that question might be um
theological political
um economic representational um
paul and i didn't have a chance to talk
about media but one of the frames for
thinking about the survivor as a figure
is thinking about survival actually in
relationship to
things like um absence and presence as
they
appear in both contemporary media and
then um
historically and debates about
representation in christianity so
um uh so yes
so um survival is is a way i would say
opposing
opposing this question and keeping it
open as a question
okay i'm going to go on to another
question
this one says in the opening of your
book you identify the jew with survival
a genealogy of survival can look
differently and less christian if
originated in the jew as a stranger
quote unquote in modernity the lineage
arrives from zimmer via buber then yamin
and arent
et cetera the stranger may point towards
a different ethics and theopolitics of
survival in the christianized
reading by a gunban curious to hear your
thoughts
so the question is is whether the
stranger is a
potentially more productive figure than
survival it seems that there is a
survival attached to the stranger and it
might have a different ethics associated
with it
um it might i don't know i don't i
haven't i haven't thought too much about
the stranger but it's an interesting
uh it's interesting pairing with um
survival um um i'll have to think a
little bit more about that um
i don't have anything um it is too
concrete to say about the moment
in your portrayals the survivor except
maybe for benjamin
is always our survivor the survivor of
our group
a survivor that that belongs somewhere
and that carries the belonging with them
even into an alien territory
exiles for one right i mean
um this this reminds me um
this is helpful actually um uh
you know one one question that that um
the question of political theology of
survival brings up um
in relationship to um kind of famous
things in the field
the king's two bodies and so forth is
the degree to which survival is actually
uh
is always a function of a community um
the self and the other
uh multiplicity and individuality and so
thinking about what the stranger might
be in relationship to the way that
survival always forms a community of say
inclusion and exclusion could be an
interesting way of thinking about um
opening that up but i have to give it a
little bit more thought
yeah you write in a in chapter four on
the sovereign
about figures of sovereignty even in the
age of
pure sovereignty absolute sovereignty as
being kind of survivors of god
and in a sense the sovereign has to
survive into modernity sovereignty does
in other forms the one christ who says
this is my body
the sovereign who says let's say
has to take different forms in modernity
and already that
you show is active in hamlet
where you do a marvelous reading of
hamlet
i wonder if you think those forms are
um proliferating if you
see them in places as you look around
now
uh the ones that call back to a
theological model that
are the gods uber laban in disguise
well i'm going to keep this on um
a bit of a theoretical level but um i
have been wondering
recently um and i'm actually not sure
i'm committed to this claim so i'll be
curious to
hear what you think paul but um you know
one way of talking about the one popular
way
i'm coming out of foucault for talking
about the difference between epochs of
say power would be sovereignty
um as a kind of singular form and then
something like
um to make uh so you have to make die
and
live versus to make live and let die but
if um in the classical
absolutist sovereign sense the sovereign
is already a kind of eucharistic body
um it's already making live um the
community is already
um sustained in some way
by um by the king's body
so it it is possible that um uh
um the very periodization that foucault
uses is actually
bound up some way with um uh
this um strange history of the king's
three bodies or four bodies or
however many bodies it may have yeah i
guess
in europe the french revolution would be
a good turning point there
if this the sovereign can carry the
survival problem
of god for the people the people are
really free but once the people have to
carry it
and have to continually support the
sovereignty through their will
then you have to make the people survive
a thought i'm going back to the
questions um
yes the question is could you talk a
little bit or does your book talk about
the etymologies and differing linguistic
histories of the latinate versions of
survival and the germanic terms
that aren't benny mean rose and swag use
iberle and fort laden what are the
important differences
and could you talk about that right so
um
it does um um so the difference is
between um
say german french and english appear
throughout to the extent that i'm
reading texts that move through these
languages
the latin distinctions are interesting
as well
um i actually i developed this a little
bit less um
in the book than elsewhere but um
um etymologically and people like
ben neeson's so poor
the the term survival has has often been
linked to
um superstition or superstar um and so
there's actually a kind of dual and sort
of unclear etymology of where
um the english term or the french term
um survival comes from
and it hasn't really been um it hasn't
really been uh
uh looked at i think from from this
historical linguistic standpoint but
um much like religion there's a kind of
uh
doubling of survival genealogy that
remains
unclear as to the um source super vive
superstar and
i bring this out um somewhat in the book
but
um um focus more on one than the other
here's another question towards benjamin
about super life hyperlife and
translation is the super life of a text
not its survival but its fracture is
fracture a different mode of survival
that departs from the christian
theological imposition
um
that sounds possible yes i i mean i i
would i would need to think about
we need to think about that a little bit
more in relationship to benjamin's text
um i mean the claim about
um the claim about the term uba
laban in um
in the benny means task of the
translator essay
is that actually he's borrowing the way
that he uses the term and his essay on
romanticism
as a kind of um higher life um but that
this isn't necessarily the higher life
of the text
it's the um uh um
moment at the very end of the essay when
um
benjamin tries to articulate the um
uh holy text or holy uh the
bible as a text that doesn't need to be
translated because it's already
um it's already freely translating in
some kind of in the sense that it
actually produces language as opposed to
um uh is derivative in some way um and
so
is um stands there and so this question
of fracture across the rest of the essay
um it would be interesting to read those
two moments more in tension than i do
um in the text and think about whether
that question of fracture could depart
in some way from
from the link between
sovereignty and uber their wholeness
okay here's a here's a question thank
you
this is a question about language and
another one there's a lot of interest in
this
if you premise the book upon the
question who is speaking about survival
this viewer is wondering about the
preposition about
can you separate language and speaking
as a medium of articulation from
survival as its object
wouldn't the speaking and the language
be a form of survival
following benjamin blanchard
can you talk about survival before
talking about the survival structure of
talking
um right i think i think um that sounds
um
right to me though if i'm understanding
the question correctly
um there seems to be a kind of um
say fraud opposition between what do we
mean to think about survival
as a particular word term
part of a particular language a
particular translation history and what
do i mean to generalize
survival um as a kind of universalizing
structure for what it means to speak
in the first place and um obviously in
the book i take the kind of
first attack i think that um gary dawes
um uh um sort of
30-year project of generalizing survival
has its own strategies
um behind it that survival can't be
understood necessarily the kind of
exceptional position that needs to be
understood
um as a kind of substructure for
thinking about
um language life in general um
um which is um which is very interesting
i think
um and in some ways um the inspiration
for the way that this
book works but i try to go in a
different direction by thinking about
um how even that generalization operates
perhaps within a particular closure
or particular history of say metaphysics
chris theology christianity
um and so in that sense um it would try
to provisionalize this claim about the
generalization of survival
as a structure of speaking right if i'm
again if i'm understanding this
question yeah i agree it would seem to
me that
it's begging the question to impose
survival and language
but it's true the questioner is right
that there is a kind of circular issue
there
and maybe it really depends on
whether we can speak differently out of
our past
that is to use language differently
before we can start to talk about
survival differently i want to ask you
now
i think we've come to the end of our
questions for now but people are welcome
to ask
a few more we have a few minutes left
i want to ask you about psychology
because there's a lot of first of all
psychological attachment
to the idea of survival but psychology
is imagined in freud as you deal with
him as a kind of
survival from childhood you talk about
trauma as one model of this
maybe you could talk a little bit about
the difference between this
psychiatric invention of the concept of
the survivor by robert j
lifton which you address in your
prologue your introduction and freud's
trying to come to terms with rests and
revenues and remainders
that seem to structure the psyche
right so i'm going to try to answer this
question a little bit um uh
weekly i think um which is that one of
the arguments of
the book um is that um
already in freud's lifetime but really
in the post-war period um people like
lifton but then also
important trauma theorists like kathy
karuth and and so forth
um use survival to describe a whole
series of
um things um that emerge out of
psychoanalysis
and um um the question i want to ask is
whether
um survival actually as a term is
a freudian concept which is to say in
freud's text is survival
a concept like say the reality principle
or the death drive
um something that freud reflects on as a
particular category in need of
um further examination and the turn then
to this um i read a
short dream um that freud looks at um
in the interpretation of dreams um is
um a place where he actually is invested
in
the language of um or
actually works um with a particular um
word as opposed to it being imposed on
the freudian corpus
and what emerges from that is this kind
of strange transferential
dialectic between a kind of search for a
sovereign triumphalism what it means to
stand
um at a grave over
the loss of a loved one um and the sense
that actually
um um there are no sovereign singular
individuals we are all
kind of ghostly uh replications
of everyone else and that this is
freud's great anxiety um
and so the question for me that is with
freud is
um to try to think linguistically or in
terms of translation about um
how important survival has become to
thinking about psychoanalysis in the
post-war period
um and again in figures like
karuth how it's often linked to
jewish survival that much of the
potent force of that comes out of a
reading of moses and monotheism and so i
try to move this
back and suggest that freud's actually
working with a um
series a kind of christian archive in
that particular moment in the dream
yeah the dream is really spectacular
maybe i'll just say a little about it we
can talk about the dream to close out
the session
freud has a dream in in which he is in
the laboratory
of his former teacher he hears a knock
on the door and the dead professor
fleischel
is there incidentally it's a
fleshy visitor whose name is flesh
basically little flesh
and freud goes through meeting a whole
set of people who have caused him
trouble including
fleece who is his kind of ego
ideal and bait noir
and he's gripped by strange effects
he sees a sign that says non-vixen
and he ends up thinking that fleischer
had been only an
apparition a revenant it's a very
complicated dream which you
carry through the rest of the chapter
it seems to me that whatever there is
about survival here
is really about rivalry in a sense you
were saying that
and i wonder if there's a real cynical
reading of survivor here
which is something like uh it is
an imagined uh
escape from struggle or an imagined
triumph i guess in the way we've been
talking about it but now in a social
sense
where you could come out on top without
actually having to you know you just
kill everybody
and it's a death wish
right right no i think i think it's this
kind of dream
a maybe it's a terrifying dream but
dream of absolute sovereignty
somehow for freud in this um
rivalrous um mode as you've been saying
um and i think you know um in terms of
the reception of freud this is
this is more or less um um kennedy's
strange post-war assessment of the
survivor not that the survivor is a
victim that needs to be um thought of uh
uh
not in the sense of a victim but
actually um mankind's worst evil as uh
quote-unquote as
he puts it in that um book as which he's
taking from freud
the the survivor as this triumphant
sovereign figure dreaming of killing
all of those uh around um and it's
this has a kind of reception as well
into
people like uh imbembe and cavarero and
so forth so
this this peculiar
language of sovereign survivalism in
freud um has its own kind of resonance
into the
present i think and this dream i think
is one
place where you really see that happen
there's as usual in freud there's a
beautiful attack of conscience
in that the repressed survives
but it always comes back as something
else so there's a disturbing element
to survival that doesn't allow you to
triumph over anything ever
right right i don't know if you would
call this survival exactly if something
survives as something that it never was
and at a certain point um you or he
talked about i think it's freud who
talks about this either as of childhood
memory
or the stuff of psychoanalysis or as a
fantasy
so i wonder if you would just help us
end by talking about
um the kind of perspective and
fantasmatic attachments
to the idea of survival um it seems to
me that
um it has a lot and it does a lot of
work psychologically
even if not in the way that lifton
imagined i don't know if you consider
that at all or think about
testimonies um but i wonder if you could
talk about that
can you say a little a little more paul
what what um sounds like you you have a
thought about
uh about this well i mean in a way
um
[Music]
i'm thinking that um
you do this great job of genealogizing
and showing
here's a good example and showing how
these
uh german jewish marginally jewish
marginally german figures
who have um vexed relationships to both
take up this term and how this offers a
really good backdrop for maybe changing
our
attachment to survivor for the
um showa discourse
but it does seem also that there are
let's say positive dialectical moments
to it and it allows you to
process something or put something in a
in a particular place
that as you say it holds on to
complexity
um uh as freud is gripped by strange
affects
in a sense it because nobody knows what
it means really
it's an ambiguous highly ambiguous term
and it might be doing the work of
maintaining the ambiguity
like the repressed does this the term
keeps coming back wonder if you have a
sense of what its positive work is
for let's say post showa
understanding right i mean i think you
know even even historically to the
extent that
that um some significant work has been
done on thinking about
this in the um post-holocaust period um
you know it's related to it's related to
agency is
you know this idea perhaps um in certain
contexts in the post-war period you have
a kind of
lack of resistance um you know
quote-unquote sheeps to the slaughter
kind of
accusations or perhaps collaboration
but negatively tinged and survival
provided a kind of
agency for thinking about what it might
mean to
find strength in moments of suffering
and so forth
um so yeah so i mean survival has has
this
this um um and as you said because it's
so ambiguous it holds together
so much that um it has this
this flexibility to be used in all sorts
of
different contexts different ways of not
just extreme historical situations but
even in
everyday life um i guess
um effectively is while the discourse on
the survivor survival is tied to a
particular um
context it kind of colonizes the whole
field
right if it's so ambiguous and it takes
up um so much perpetrator and victim
ghostly uh multiplicity and singularity
um it ends up being an organizing frame
for thinking about
um as i said earlier subjectivity in
general
in some way and the question is whether
it really
has exhausted in some way um
all of the dialectical possibilities or
if um
there's something affectively familiar
about the term survival
and the figure of the survivor um and
that doing
this genealogical work could provide a
kind of
um set of boundaries for thinking about
what it might mean to speak in different
terms even if it's
in uh say non-latinate languages
are there other um other
discourses that have their own poetics
their own say materialism about them
that aren't that don't produce the same
kind of images as
um survival does in their familiarity at
least so that's
that's um that's my sense of the
issue seems like a great place to
close yeah i want to say thank you so
much to both of you
um that was just a really um fascinating
discussion and you know to adam
i you know i i've just only started the
book but it's
um it's such it's such an interesting
book and you describe
you explain the these concepts in such a
lucid way it's really really a triumph
and i think
um i really recommend to everyone
interested in these questions
i think it's really going to be just an
important book so congratulations on
that
and i just want to end by uh giving a
little plug for our
next uh anti-semitism event which is
alex ross the music critic of the new
yorker is going to be
uh talking to us about wagner and
anti-semitism
co-sponsored by the german department
again so thank you
uh to paul for that and that is going to
be on uh
wednesday april 28th so you should all
get
the um uh call to register for that and
i hope to see you then
thank you again to adam to paul to all
of you
and uh have a good evening